What are the steps we go through when we want to get access to a computer system?
We often refer to these as the access system.
We often refer to these as the access control services.
There's four major access control services.
Essentially the steps that we have to go through to get access to a system and use that system.
Think about this. When you walk up to a computer system and you jiggle a mouse, what's the first thing that you need to do to get access to that system?
Hopefully, jiggling the mouse did just entirely unlock the system and give you full access.
Hopefully, there's some sort of access control services in place.
What's the first thing that you need to do to get access to a system?
The first thing you need to do is identification. Identification is where you assert your identity to the system.
You somehow uniquely identify yourself with a username or maybe biometric data.
So that is identification. It's where I identify myself to a system.
And hopefully, just typing in my username or which doesn't give me full access to the system.
Because the next step is authentication.
This is where the system needs to verify my identity.
It has to somehow figure out am I actually who I say am.
So how can the system authenticate me? Verify my identity.
Well, there are three factors of authentication.
There's authentication by knowledge, something you know.
There's authentication by ownership, something you have.
And there's authentication by characteristic, how you behave or your physiology.
So those are the three factors of authentication.
And we'll get into those in a lot more detail later on.
Okay, so step one, I assert my identity, identified myself.
Step two, I authenticated myself somehow.
What's the next step? It's authorization.
This is where the system determines exactly what my access is going to be.
This is where we apply those principles we've already talked about, like least privilege.
Need to know separation of duties.
You don't want to authorize someone to have access beyond anything that they need to do their job.
So that is the authorization step.
There's one final and in fact, most important step.
And that is accountability.
The whole reason that we do access control is to make users accountable for their actions on a system.
Because this is so incredibly important, we in fact give this a special name.
We call it the principle of access control.
So the whole reason and listen very carefully here because there's often questions on this.
The whole principle of access control is accountability.
How do you achieve accountability?
Well, you have to have uniquely identified someone properly authenticated them, properly authorize them,
and then log in monitor what they're doing on the system to then and only then make them accountable for their actions on the system.
That is the principle of access control.
Let's talk about how we identify ourselves.
Identification ideally needs to be unique.
You do not want to have shared user accounts.
It's a very bad idea for 50 people in the organization to have all share one admin account.
So ideally identification needs to be unique.
Tied to a particular individual.
And the way that we identify ourselves are examples like I've already given.
User ID, account number, badges, which is a name and a picture.
We can even use biometrics for identification.
Some good practices around identification, like I said, unique,
should also not be descriptive of your job.
So for instance, if I was the network administrator, I'd probably call myself network administrator god.
And the problem with that is that if there's any attackers on our environment,
what account are they going to try and break and do first, do you think?
Probably the network administrator god account.
The other problem is that people change roles.
And what would inevitably probably happen to me is I would get demoted.
And I would no longer be network administrator god.
Now it would be network administrator lackey.
And my username would no longer apply to the role that I was in.
So it's not good for the roles to be tied to a particular description of what they someone does.
And then the final piece is secure issuance.
You need some way of getting someone their credentials securely.
So you don't ever just want to write out someone's username and password on a sticky note and leave it on their monitor.
I mean, we're security people.
We know better than that.
You got to stick it on a sticky note on the bottom of their keyboard.
That's how we do secure issuance, right?
Of course not, right?
But you need a secure issuance process, some way of getting these credentials to someone securely.
And the next few videos we'll talk about how we do these factors of authentication in more detail,
authentication by knowledge, ownership and characteristic.